so
patient wilfred ayers talks to surgeon d
d monroe
so mr ayers
if this proves to be a cancer of the
lung
your outlook or your prognosis
is almost 100
nil
for any length of time
and with operation and complete removal
of the tumor and the tumor-bearing area
you have a reasonably good outlook but
then once it's completed the only thing
to do is to go back to your job and live
with optimism and quit smoking and quit
smoking
ayers will walk these streets again but
minus the cigarette and minus a lung
in a week he will have a major operation
which we will see and which may save his
life
last year in north america 50 000 people
died from cancer of the lung a disease
which has become a major killer only
since the smoking of cigarettes has
become epidemic
many more thousands died of coronary
heart disease or were disabled by
chronic bronchitis emphysema and other
illnesses which medical men the world
over say can be related directly to the
smoking of cigarettes
almost 150 years ago charles lamb wrote
for thy sake tobacco i would do anything
but die
medical men say too many people are
doing just that
uh
history of heavy smoking for a good
number of years would you care to
make give any opinion as to the
relationship between
his smoking and the fact that he appears
now with the proven
bronchogenic carcinoma of the squamous
cell variety
i definitely feel that it did have a
relationship too this morning but i
don't think we can prove
i think there's
no question but
prolonged
cigarette smoking is
responsible i presume for carcinoma
certainly these people get carcinoma and
the logical assumption is the
responsibility of the cigarettes now
what
in the cigarette smoking is responsible
for it i don't think we can say at all
whether or not it's tar or
some uh
other product of combustion is not at
all but
clear
but i think the association is clear and
i think that it is certainly
more than adequate to be acted upon
in in advising people
whether or not to smoke and you will be
the first one i'm sure will agree that
there are other deleterious effects of
smoking
that perhaps haven't got the fatality of
a cancer of the lung but from an
economic point of view and from the
point of view of disabling a person
they're equally as important and i'm
talking particularly about the chronic
bronchitic and the emphysema people
coronary artery disease that seems to
have some association
certainly there are some cases where
this appears to be
clear-cut
there is a time-honored association with
burger's disease uh there's no doubt
that
there are a number of areas of medicine
where
you can get this deleterious association
between disease and smoking
i've done the stupidest thing i've
smoked uh
cigarettes before breakfast before
having anything three and four
cigarettes for you ever since i get out
of bed which is i think is
no good to anybody and my wife says to
me several times she says why ever don't
you stop smoking with that cop
you've always had a car
always found that i coughed
quite heavily after i had a smoke
because i always inhale my smoke
yes what was the symptom or the uh
reason that motivated you to seek the
advice of a doctor in the first place
well i for a pastor and nine months when
i went to see dr halley's i had a streak
of blood on my phlegm
seeing your future he must be them
that's so i thought well
this has gone far enough and my wife
said why don't you go and see the doctor
so i said i will i'll make up my mind
one of these days i didn't know what i
was involving myself when was that this
is important yes i should say about uh
uh nine months ago and uh when did you
go to the doctor
it was uh a month ago just a month ago
so you waited eight months i waited
eight months why well i thought it was a
blood vessel i'd broken and when i
coughed i wasn't
i put these x-rays up here not
specifically for you to completely
understand them but to give you a rough
idea of what your problem is now if you
look at this x-ray here
you'll see that you have a shadow which
is generalized in the upper part of the
left lung and if you compare this to the
right lung you'll see that there's a
difference
in the degree of penetration on both
sides what this represents is that you
have a complete obstruction to the upper
lobe of your left lung
now let me be very frank with you mr
ayers the thing that we're all concerned
about this day
is the fact that this could very likely
be a tumor
that's obstructing your airway this
tumor
is undoubtedly likely to be a malignant
tumor and in other words it's to be a
cancer
and if it proves to be a cancer the only
satisfactory treatment is to remove it
completely
this will mean that you will lose your
left lung and the other lung is good
isn't it oh as far as we know it's an
excellent different condition so that uh
that is uh one reason why
i think
that the left lung should come out i
little did i know till i came in here
that i had only a long and a half or
less all right we'll carry on with the
bronchoscopy examination tomorrow and
after that there will be no further
delay
if it's indicated uh we'll take you to
surgery yes
now mr ayers we're going to carry out
this bronchoscopy procedure that i
explained to you uh yesterday
and this is the instrument the light is
on the end and it's hollow and we put
this through your air tree and this is
just a simple diagram of your air tree
with the lung at the side now pay no
attention to this side this is your left
lung
and this is the part that is involved in
other words
this part of your lung which is your
upper lobe is collapsed because there's
something plugging the airway going into
it
right here you have a
bird's eye view so to speak of the air
tree as we look sideways
through a special little instrument
that's actually a miniature periscope
that we can look at a right angle
and these openings here which feed air
into this upper lobe are plugged
and the object of this
is to put down the bronchoscope we turn
your head to the side to line it up and
we have it lying in here the main airway
going to the entire left lung
and then we look sideways into this left
upper low bronchus
and we observe directly with the human
eye
exactly what the condition and the
nature of that air tube is and this is
the object of the examination i don't
think it'll bother you very much no
we'll do it under local anesthesia we'll
freeze your throat and uh i think you'll
find it uh very easy okay then talk
about that
if tommy will get safe i'll be a little
difficult to swallow for you so
that would be an indication that you
start to get frozen
okay that's fine
yeah ready to uh
just lie down sir
fine thank you just raise your head sir
raise your head and i'll put it down
i don't think you'll find this
examination of upset guitar so just
what size is this number
seven eight that's fine
just stick out your tongue sir
and just relax
nice and easy
that's it
no problem there at all
could i have to poorly scope these
all right
now we're right in your main airway now
mr ayres
and we're looking down
into your main airway we can see the two
divisions
now we have these little telescopic
instruments that i was talking to you
about and we've got this through the
hollow tube
and we're looking on the interior of
your airway
and we can see it very nicely i'll have
a right angle scope now
and now we're going to put in the
telescope that's
that's a miniature periscope so we can
look sideways
and with this instrument we're able to
see
side branches directly
you're doing very well mr airs there's
no problem here at all and we'll soon be
finished
all right mr eric we're all finished
just sit up there
i'll take this off your head
just swing your feet over the side
now did we bother you very much no
stopped alone
no bothering no bothering no trouble
yeah
well we've determined that your right
lung looks very clear and the your left
the main part of your left airway is
fine
and that our suspicions that the left
upper lobe the airway was blocked has
been confirmed
and uh so this is plugged and it's
plugged by a tumorous growth
so our next job now is uh to fix you up
and get rid of this
and uh we'll proceed with that
next week
sure
okay mr ayers thank you
not all smokers have the reasons to
stuff that wilfred ayers has
but not all who developed cancer have
the warnings he had either
cancer is a silent killer and more often
than not does not proclaim its onset
and doctors now urge that those who
smoke have x-rays twice a year too many
smokers come with their problems too
late when surgery or radiation or other
treatments cannot cure them
breathing tests help determine how he
will function on only one lung deep
breath and blow and if i ring the bell
you're gonna give me a cigarette oh i
thought it would stop smoking
blow keep flowing keep blowing keep
blowing as much as you can
i'm really interested in this oxygen
uptake this is really when i'm visibly
one along against the other easy
the capacity of each separate lung can
be plotted on a
spirometer that's all you need
we just want one against the other
anyways i want to in case i have to
recover
the whole thing i think we better give
them some more numerals
this is the moment of truth
but they're bang on you know
that thing's in there real tight
i mean it's good it's a good
differential boundary
physical examination was essentially
unremarkable apart from the fact that
there was gross abnormality in the
respiratory sounds in his left upper
chest
suggesting a collapse of his left upper
lobe
the rest of the physical examination was
negative
and the chest x-ray was grossly abnormal
he's had extensive investigations uh
many of which are uh of little interest
because they're essentially normal
including electrocardiograph and his
pulmonary function studies has he lost
any weight does he have any
constitutional symptoms he no weight
loss skull sir
when i first saw the patient he was an
extremely healthy looking man and i
think almost clinically you could tell
that
he wouldn't present a risk to surgery
and i think it's his only chance for a
possible cure of his disease
he has no evidence of cardiovascular
disease none whatsoever
may we see the x-rays
now the radiological findings are such
that they indicate an obstruction
in uh in the left upper low bunkers sir
would you call the remainder of his lung
normal the remainder of his left lung is
normal
as
his right lung shows no evidence of any
disease
we took a biopsy from these
tumor mass and dr berlin can tell us
about anthony
yes
he saw that squamous cell carcinoma
there's no doubt about it and no
symptomatology elsewhere that would
suggest extra thoracic no no no
the pulmonary function studies will be
more helpful
in
making sure that he has enough reserve
to withstand this sort of surgery
who used up the well sir he had a vital
capacity done maximum breathing capacity
time vital capacity and pulmonary
diffusion capacity
with carbon monoxide uptake the opinion
of the pulmonary function consultant
was
in summary the findings reported above
are reasonably good for a male in this
age group the flow rates are perhaps a
little bit down not as much as i would
expect with this long history of smoking
that his diffusing capacity was normal
um i wouldn't consider these a
contraindication to any to a
pneumonectomy
that's pollock penny
i
agree with
general course of the spectrometer
and i think in this case
operation is a
best way to proceed
as a result of the anaesthetic you pile
up secretions in your chest and it's
difficult for you to cough
and
the breathing exercises can make this
simpler for you so let's just check them
again okay you don't have to fear
coughing uh after the operation mr ear
because i'll be supporting your incision
so just like specs again with the
breathing in
and out
short breath in
long breath out and calm
and again
there is little hope among medical men
that those who now smoke will stop
despite new medical knowledge that much
lung damage can be reversed by stopping
they only hope that examples like mr
ayers will cause non-smokers not to
begin
good morning mrs
how how do you feel about surgery now oh
i uh the way i look at it is this it's a
must
to what dr monroe and other doctors have
told me and uh i put myself into their
hands completely i mean he told me once
that he said he
uh a little while back there that he
didn't get too much chance for my life
seriously not uh i didn't have something
done i've heard that there's lots of uh
individuals going around with one lung
as a matter of fact as a lady i know
very well through uh
daily contact sometimes in a store you
see and
she only has one line i think that uh
you can't tell any difference whether
she's got one or half a dozen uh maybe i
could recommend that you try to rest as
much as you can
and to relax as much as you can when i
start to come too
from the uh
anaesthetic equality yeah
um
am i likely to get into a tantrum right
get mad or no no no you were you were
weak i had that experience once
uh they uh clubbed the ether uh over
here and i was asleep at seven o'clock
came round about midnight the same uh
that was where i was wounded you know
for my leg and
that took about twelve of them and i was
cursing everybody around me you know
everything wasn't funny i loved my uh
yes well mr ears there is nothing to
that i just had my little bath there
because i won't want to uh
cause any commotion like that you know
actually
done
uh
by smoking you know what i mean i've
left it to the doctors to say that but
when i was told not to smoke i had not
coughed
man i should have taken my
daily beloved wife's advice years ago
and cut down on the smoking you know
sometimes you get into a little bit of a
uh
sometimes you i mean you get into a jam
and first thing you do is pick up
cigarette you keep smoking and smoking
and smoking you know
when you're told that you haven't only
got and that the the prospects in life
is not very far ahead of you you know
then you sit up and take notice because
life is sweet
blood pressure is 130.
sir
we're injecting the pentathol in the
intravenous now
and you'll just fall off to sleep very
quietly very presently
you may notice the little peculiar taste
or smell
something like onions or garlic
we are now ventilating only the right
lung
left lung is excluded from the airway
blood pressure 120.
now
let the respirator the automatic
respirator take over
control of ventilation
now we're
ready to position the patient for the
surgery
to help position his legs properly
heart rate has speeded up now
all right now uh
we're about to make the incision
after brendol everything all right
this particular patient will undoubtedly
take out a rib
to facilitate the exposure
can i hold it
is
foreign
you know
it's gonna come that's the only question
it seems to be it's gonna come but it's
not uh
it's not the most favorable stories
actually this guy's probably gonna find
and there's nothing in the media style
area up above
it seems to remain the pulmonary artery
and maybe the superior pulmonary veins
well we just have to work away but we
get the thing cleared out
right we're just about we're
just about ready to sever the lungs
now what i have in my hand here is just
the air tube and the other rear tube
going together long branches right there
we're going to put a clamp across it
right here this is a soft clamp
it's gentle to the tissues
and we'll clamp the air tube
like so now i'm just giving a nice
please i think we should set that a
little further down rob taylor
i will cover
the connections here and as we do
dr papari keeps cutting it out
and there we are
here's what we've been after
this morning is to remove this
lung containing the tumor mask which i
have in my fingers here
that the beeland will take this and
demonstrate
but all the big vessels and everything
that's come off the house are all tied
off here
this is an important side of course
the side is next to the heart
so that we can
have a good view of this
neoplasm or tumor
we start from the upper lobe and we'll
go down to the base of the wall
here is the tumor
in the upper lobe
occupying almost half of it it's not a
very large tumor just i would say medium
size
it is a hard white mass
that you can see here
the rest of the tissue is soft and
spongy and this tumor is very hard it is
fairly well demarcated
and the indefinite prognosis can be
established only after microscopic
examination
how do you feel now
oh we're not too bad not too bad the
operation's all over
thank you yeah
try to keep your eyes open
now you take a deep breath for
deep
and out
and in
out that's it
you try to give us a smile now
sure
wilfred airs has opened his eyes again
on a world that wears a cigarette in its
face
where he will have to live with
temptations that confront a smoker
wherever he looks and listens
where persuasion filters out of the mind
of the beholder the consciousness of the
harms that medicine now definitely
attributes to cigarettes
a world whose governments are split
between the revenues they gain from
cigarettes
and the responsibility they feel for the
health of their peoples
a world that seems to have no ready
answer to the question of how far laws
should go
in curbing the rights of people to make
their own choices
and take their own consequences
a world where the young are taking ever
earlier to a habit that public health
associations have estimated will claim
the lives of millions who are now school
children
before they reach the age of 70.
oh
foreign
you